Donald Trump looks scared as hell in a
deranged new video attacking the recent
report from the January 6 Trump Riot
committee we're going to look at the
clip this guy seems nervous this guy
seems scared even though I don't believe
he will see even a single day inside of
a prison cell no matter what happens he
doesn't want to be the indicted
president he doesn't want to have the
next four years of his life who knows
how many years he has left tied up
dealing with a criminal trial look at
Trump check this out
we wanted security we wanted safety
there was no Insurrection and there
wasn't going to be an Insurrection it
was made up by these sick people I've
never seen Trump look like this behave
like this talk like this Nancy Pelosi
and the D.C mayor refused if they'd
listen to me my recommendation none of
this would have happened now remember
we've learned since first Trump kept
saying I wanted 10 to 20 000 troops to
protect the capital and Nancy Pelosi
turned him down and what we realized was
Nancy Pelosi didn't turn anything down
Trump didn't request 10 to 20 000 troops
to protect the capital it's actually
even sicker we've now learned Trump
wanted 10 000 troops to protect him on
January 6th him not to protect the
capital to protect him it's insane that
that's actually the truth of the matter
and you wouldn't have heard about
January 6th as we know it they covered
up multiple tweets and they covered up
video which were censored by Twitter and
the FBI in which I called for Law and
Order and for no violence this this
should be an exhibit at whatever trial
is forthcoming and then they pushed and
observed and discredited story where I
supposedly lunch for the steering wheel
in an attempt to commandeer a
presidential limousine think of it I
lunged for a steering wheel and they
believed that story nobody believes that
story the committee jump Cuts doing a
lot of work here I can only imagine what
the experience of watching Trump film
this was like barely even discussed the
catastrophic security failures at the
Capitol and they didn't discuss the
other thing the reason that everybody
went there the election which was a
corrupt disaster they did not discuss
why the doors were flung wide open for
people to walk right in and they didn't
discuss the role of federal informants
most importantly the unselect committee
did not produce a single shred of
evidence that I in any way intended or
wanted violence at our Capital the
evidence does not exist because the
claim is baseless and a monstrous lie
they know it it's just like the
russia-russia Russia hoax this is
absolutely no different it's
misinformation the only thing they're
good at cheating in elections
misinformation remember there was no
cheating in the election by democrats
the events of January 6 were not an
Insurrection they were a protest that
tragically got out of control and which
the left has been weaponizing ever since
to censor spion and persecute American
citizens the entire phony hoax is about
taking away your speech taking away your
vote and taking away your freedom these
are sick people these are marxists and
they're very dangerous and very big now
as you know there would really be no
connection between Marxism and any of
the things that Donald Trump is talking
about that is unhinged and understand
that with the jump Cuts where it's like
Trump's in a different part of the
screen every time they cut it and we
know why this happens because we've seen
the uncensored video of Trump trying to
record these things he can barely speak
and it's really just a triggering
experience for him I can only imagine
that given that this was the best video
they could put together
that this guy was just exploding behind
the scenes about this thing he seemed
scared he seems terrified he doesn't
want to be the indicted president which
he may be I don't know what the big 2023
story is going to be but if I were a
betting man at this point I might be
saying it's the Trump indictment we will
see we will take a break and be back
right after this
one of our sponsors today is fume fume
is on a mission to accelerate Humanity's
breakup from the bad habits that consume
far too many of us including ones that
harm our health fume is a natural
diffusive device that uses plants and
Behavioral Science to trade out your
negative habit for a positive one fume
is not a vape it's a non-electronic
device designed to transform your
negative habits instead of PODS filled
with potentially harmful chemicals like
a vape fume uses cores infused with
plants like peppermint and cinnamon for
delicious natural flavors fumes new
version 2 model is Snappy and tactile
with an adjustable airflow dial and a
magnetic end cap that's fun to fidget
with it's fume's goal to make switching
easy or even enjoyable they have
thousands of five star reviews from
people just like you who have
successfully switched when other
Solutions didn't work how head to
trifum.com and use the code Pacman to
get 10 off today when you get the
journey pack which comes with three
unique flavors and the new version to
fume the link is down below